alors on a fait un classement des 50
meilleures blagues
regardez vous allez voir de la 50e à la
46e place et je crois un philippe que tu
es très très bien classés donc tu vas
avoir regardé de la 50e à la 46e c'est
parti
[Musique]
la bonne soeur aller dans un taxi c'est
une très belle nuit par direct sur le
petit regard dans le rétro il arrive pas
des vignes beauté incroyable et je me
sens à personne dit elle dit que si ce
poste vous vous regardez plus dans le
rétro que que devant vous on va avoir un
accident et dit non c'est pas ça mais tu
veux c'est tellement belle t mon mon
fantasme à moi ce serait un jour
d'embrasser une bonne soeur aussi belle
que vous monsieur m'a dit écoutez il n'y
a pas de problème si vous êtes croyant
il part est célibataire mais dit je suis
croyant je suis croyant je suis
célibataire des animaux
garez-vous sur le côté hier ce côté le
petit buzz derrière et lui roule une
gamelle mais ton ferme et non ça va
jamais en nombre à c'est tout lui doit
sa langue sur les yeux dans les crocs
donné par te gaver incroyable hiraumont
d'avaya hui sommet devrait il se met à
pleurer
c'est en conduisant il est là il
sanglote ça dit mais qu'est ce qui vous
a rédigé sanglote parce que je suis un
gros menteur je suis pas croyant je suis
marié je suis mayer a servi ses bagages
moi je m'appelle raymond je retiens
nouvelle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est un mec qui l'ont dans un bistrot
il fait bon jour monsieur sait combien
le coca petit vif ici ça qu il fait rien
de moins qu'au cas le barman il fait
tous les mois 10 euros justement on va
vous avez 10 et 5 euros fait 6-5 rôle
coca synchro le service adacore ben
voilà dix ans mais le barman durant cinq
ans il fait pourquoi vous moins de cinq
ans y fait ce que j bonne coca serbe est
qu'il arrive on l'appelle audi vient ta
femme à la coucher live au courant la
clinique iran qui dit loulou mon fils
sinon mon physique et attendez attendez
qu'on vous dise un truc sur eugène
arrive du foot je te parle ton fils aîné
mais il n'a pas de bras et comment elles
à prendre un bain il n'a pas bradé
décembre à des bosses pas grave on va
l'aimer quand même évoque pour un lait
dans un champ médias le temps c'est pas
fini qu'elle n'a pas de jambes et
commence une madeleine c'est quoi la
peinture poésie c'est pas grave je
l'aimé quand même c'est mon premier
enfant je crois bien faire des croquis
des mâts attendez j'ai pas finir à
hoëdic wali la paquet
[Rires]
rentrez vous allez voir l'iran c'était
qu'une eau est une ong du nord et du
bronze pas l'algérie l'aimé et prend
l'aurait dit je t'aime office a dit sale
parler il est sourd
[Musique]
un mec sort de chez lui hier matin pour
aller travailler
il ya un type qui est en bas de chez lui
et qui en le voyant passe en libye du
fait cocu coquille match mais je suis
vraiment pardon je me suis fait cocu
cocu et une formule soit pas bien mais
que décent le mec le swing harry fait
cocu cocu le mec descente prend le métro
le mec monde dans la même rame que lui
et de loin lui fait cocu cocu
mais que devient dingue ya jusqu'à son
bureau comme ça ibos le soir il
redescend à 18h le même éclat d'un il
fait ça cocu mais ne répond pas il fait
cocu cocu cocu il y aura de plus en plus
fort le mec dans le métro pareil le mecs
devant parce qu'au cul mais grande chez
lui dit ah ce fameux ya un truc que je
trouve quand même assez étrange
il ya un mec qui m'a suivi toute la
journée qui m'a traitée de cocu elle
fait et ba ils trouvent ça bizarre tu as
rien à venir feu non monsieur t'es pas
bien non rien dégénérés qui traite de
cocu dans la rue ça va être de ma peau
kif énorme enfin effet non mais ça va fé
web enfin quand même je vous fais un bon
mec va se coucher le matin il se
réveille il a bossé il ya le même mec
lingerie fait cocu coquet et rapporteur
en plus
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est un marabout qui est tranquille que
c'est un arabe qui arrive qui arrive au
quartier haï lâcheté la dernière
maserati malaria tue deux fois la
moyenne tous les trois sont potes sont
patents renault 5
son plan renault 5 descend de la voiture
a toujours attaché une maserati et lui
dit je t'échange maru no 5 contre eta
maserati et en plus je rajoute cette
lampe l'outil organes gilbert tu vas pas
match à savoir l'accueil comme ça je
m'en fous le talent que moi j'ai une
maserati sur le net à renault 5
udine on me regarde à satan il frotte
sur la langue comme ça il ya un génie
qui sort est idiot génie génie fait nous
du thé le génie sans une théière comme
c'est leur fait deux verres de thé il
boit il est choqué et oui du hockey
tchad maserati donne moi ta renault 5 et
l'allant évident aronofsky d'alemps il
arrive devant chez lui il est content et
klaxons klaxons klaxons sa femme et
soeurs elle voit son mari avec une
renault 5 1 comprend pas dit mais qu'est
ce qui se passe et où elle où la voiture
est tous les dix ans montrent inquiètes
montrent inquiètes dont sa femme un
monde dans la rue sur et où il frotte la
lampe il ya le génie sort idiot génie un
génie donne un gros gros sacs de bijoux
à ma femme le génie regarded yan'an
désolé moi je sais faire que du thé